hello everybody welcome to the third
Amazon Web Services tutorial video in
this video I'm going to be showing you
guys a few more things and also giving
you a quick example of a Python script
again I did already show you guys once
real quick in the beginning but I'm
gonna showing you guys one more time the
first thing I want to do is to show you
a quick file
it's the SSH configuration file and if
you remember back when I was talking
about the key how it even gave you that
warning that said if you don't have this
key will not be able to connect to your
server so that key basically it just
makes your server a lot more secure so
just even if someone gets your username
and your password they still can't log
in because they don't have the key right
so it's a good thing to have but it kind
of sucks if you lose that key so anyway
real quick I am going to show you guys
where you can go to fix that issue I
don't recommend changing and I don't
plan to change it myself but I will show
you anyway so if you're going to sudo
nano and news ETCs sh-sh HD underscore
config that will bring up the ssh
configuration file now this is there's a
whole bunch of information here and just
for the record anything with a pound
sign is commented out and so a lot of
times you'll have other options and
they'll be you know
commented out so you just uncomment them
and you you know make it show up but
anyway there's a whole bunch of stuff
here but what we're looking for is
password authentication and then there's
also somewhere around here well here's
the password authentication right now it
says no if you wanted to be able to
either do like if you wanted to use
maybe something similar to how we did
the python tutorial with pi SFTP for
example you would need password
authentication
yes because you wouldn't have a key but
then with param eco you can you can
actually have a key and still use it so
you could leave this as no and it's just
it's just a good security measure to do
it that way and the last thing there is
one other thing here I wish I could find
it I think it's closer to the top but
it's for the route login you can disable
the route login and oh yeah see like
this has permit route login is yes but
some other was there's also a thing for
disable the route login I know it's I'm
probably like missing it but at least
I'm pretty sure there's something called
disabled route logging but you could
also just uncomment this permanent route
log in but right now I believe mine is
also disabled so I couldn't even log in
the route even if I wanted anyway so
that's that file the sshd config file if
you had a my sequel file and show the
conf file for that as well but I don't
have one in neither do you at the
momentum actually sure if if my sequel
came I can't remember I seen they were
clashing mice people possibly being
installed here I'm not sure that file
exists let's do let's go back a couple
directories here a B C D and E ATC let's
see what's here you know if we had it it
would be my sequel here actually would
be like right here so I don't think we
have that pre-installed so we'd have to
install it but whenever eventually get
to that and I'll have to show you guys
that configuration file but yeah I guess
we just don't have one yet so now that
we've done that let's go back
and we want to go in to see you know
home and I already forgot what my
username was ec2 user so CD in the ec2
user and let's say we want to make an
example Python file so we'll just say ya
know run me die PI so we open up this
it's just a run meetup pi is just a text
editor basically that opens us up so
then we can say we can define a sample
function and now we can have this a
print this is just a quick example of
running a pie script and that's our
function and then we'll do sample
function here and yep save it
yes same name and now we can use Python
to run run me run me dot pi and that
will quickly run the script which is
just simply prints it oops
prints it out to console and the other
thing you can of course do is you can
just type Python and that starts you in
the Python you know command line that's
why you can do Python and then run that
specific script or you can you know
print stuff into here as I showed you in
that initial video now that's all fine
and dandy because you know all this
stuff isn't really that useful right
like we don't really see the point of
having the server just yet but what you
can do with this server is you can start
running like for example like we just
show this Python script and the other
thing role actually this wasn't the
script this was it and but the other
thing that you can do is make use of
what's called a crontab and so so with
your crontab if you go crontab that - ii
groups maybe I'm in the let's see oh I
see what the park
like why is it this organ uh we're still
in this Python editor so so that's a
good this is good tutorial how the heck
do you get out of this editor to get out
of stuff like this
it's either ctrl C or control D normally
in this case is going to be controlled
should I even know I would want to say
ctrl C normally but that's just going to
be an keyboard interrupt right so in
this case I suppose ctrl D but if you a
controlled the again usually that will
log you out I'll try that right at the
end of this video cuz I don't want to
get screwed up right during this during
this video so I'll do it at the end but
I'm pretty sure it'll log you out but
anyway so the crontab again so crontab -
E and that launches this and this is
your crontab and in here
you can specify various times that you
want something to run so you can either
run something every minute you could run
something every one hour and five
minutes you could run something every
day at 4:50 p.m. and so on it's a really
useful thing to have so definitely
something that I'll be showing you guys
pretty soon here the crontab and how to
use it and how to set it up because
again it can be kind of confusing you
look at it how to work it but anyway
it's pretty cool stuff so when you get
into the crontab I forget what the deep
I think the default editor is like is it
Pico or something like that so it's a
different editor than you're used to and
so to get out of this you have to do
hold shift colon and then do quit and
that gets you out of there the other
thing that you can do is do like editor
equals Nana and then do pran tab - e
oops
crontab space - e and then i'll open up
your crontab in nano instead and so it's
a little easier to use because sometimes
I can get kind of annoying going from
different editors but anyways so those
are just a few more basics to the things
with Amazon Web Services and really
everything we've done so far is is
actually you know having your own web
server anywhere really any VPS this is
pretty much how it goes so those are the
base
as always thanks for watching thanks for
the support of the subscriptions and
until next time